this is tumor hussein reading for
reviewer stephen petit nintendo
handhelds have thrived on their
iterations for decades from the gameboy
to the ds to the 3ds even with the
iterative nature of nintendo's handhelds
skepticism around the nintendo switch
oled is understandable since it's a
console that is riffing on arguably the
best piece of hardware nintendo has ever
made with seemingly minor improvements
but the nintendo switch oled is a marked
improvement over the original switch and
the switch light if you played a lot in
handheld mode the oled model is a
surprisingly huge upgrade and if you
don't play your switch in handheld mode
the switch oled's new screen is
impressive enough that it could change
that the switch oled has the best
display on any dedicated handheld gaming
device ever it starts with the design
itself though the system is only a
fraction of an inch larger than the
standard switch it offers nearly an
entire extra inch of screen real estate
at an even 7 inches with significantly
slimmer bezels the oled screen gives off
the illusion of being far more spacious
than its predecessor this presentational
trick if you want to call it that is
even more evident when you're playing
games from new releases like metroid red
to switch staples like the legend of
zelda breath of the wild each game we
tested looked brilliant on the new
display brighter more vivid colors make
a huge difference especially when
playing the games with harsher color
tones in spots after playing for a few
hours in a row on the oled before
jumping back to the original model it
can be surprising to see how long it
takes your eyes to adjust to the dollar
tones the most impressive aspect of the
oleds display actually isn't how it
compares to the original switches screen
it's how it compares to tvs
unless you have a 4k oled tv provided
that frame rate and overall performance
is the same which is not always the case
on the original switch the increased
clarity and more colorful picture will
make handheld mode a more enticing
option for some users
the switch oled's largest improvement is
in its name but nintendo also made some
welcome additions elsewhere the dock is
wider and more aesthetically pleasing
thanks to rounded edges on the top the
back panel that houses ports pops off
instead of having a hinged flap this is
where you'll find another notable
addition an ethernet port it's still
rather baffling that the original switch
didn't ship with a lan port forcing
users to buy third-party adapters
instead the added port unsurprisingly
makes a huge difference for download
speeds and will likely provide a more
stable online gaming connection for most
users that said the nintendo switch's
online performance troubles may stem
from factors that go beyond individual
wifi connections the original switch's
kickstand the small piece of plastic
that propped up the console to play
multiplayer without a tv wasn't ideal
the oled fixes that with a wide hinge
stand that spans the entire back panel
of the console
it's sturdy and can be placed at
multiple angles critically it doesn't
feel as if it will snap just from
messing with it though a smaller detail
the back panel has a slightly rough
finish to it and so far it seems less
prone to those scratch marks that could
pop up before long on the original model
the oled also doubles the onboard
storage from 32 gigabytes to 64. it's a
nice improvement but those who game on a
switch a lot will still need to expand
their storage via microsd since micro sd
cards are so cheap anyway there's no
reason to consider the increased storage
space as a real selling point it's more
of a little bonus while the oled model
sticks with stereo speakers audio is
sharper and louder than before it's not
a massive improvement but it's certainly
noticeable when playing with the volume
cranked up for portable play you're
still better off using a pair of nice
headphones but it's a noteworthy upgrade
for tabletop mode it's important to
stress that the internals of the system
are exactly the same as the standard
switch it has the same chipset so
overall performance between switch
models doesn't differ
i compare the load times to make sure
but nothing runs faster or smoother on
the oled the console has the same port
layout on top with the power button
volume controls headphone jack and game
card slot position from left to right
respectively and the micro sd card slot
is still located beneath the kickstand
the switch leds battery is the same as
the upgraded model that launched in 2019
it's graded to last for 4.5 to 9 hours
on a single charge battery life remains
dependent on the games and apps you're
using on the switch
if you still have a launch model switch
or switch light the increased battery
life is another welcome upgrade to
consider it's also worth noting that
nintendo hasn't updated the joy cons for
the oled model so they are still
susceptible to joy-con drift while
that's a bummer this also means that the
old led is compatible with all existing
joy-con controllers including
third-party attachments like the horiz
flip pad pro the switch o led is fairly
pricey at 350 dollars especially if you
already own a switch console that works
just fine there are some hidden costs
here too for starters you'll probably
want to grab a set of screen protectors
to protect your shiny new display while
many nintendo switch cases will fit the
oled model form fitting designs will
likely need to be replaced if you use a
grip to make the switch more ergonomic
in handheld mode you'll likely need a
new one at some point too
rigid plastic grips won't fit the oled
at all and flexible silicone models are
tight squeeze and make the ports on top
of the console inaccessible the nintendo
switch oled is a more impressive design
than you probably expect the greatly
improved display makes playing the
switch in handheld mode even more of a
joy and the other quality of life
upgrades particularly the retailing of
the dock and the kickstand offer nice
features that will be appreciated by
many if you're looking to buy a nintendo
switch for the first time you should
absolutely go for the oled model if you
can
and for those nintendo fans who are
wondering if the display is worth
shelling out 350 dollars it depends on
how much you value handheld mode overall
the switch oled is another iteration on
a piece of nintendo hardware that you
didn't know you needed
[Music]